public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marlène schiappa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir madame merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté cette invitation de
public sénat avec la fp avec les échos
et avec radio classique effectivement
avec moi ce soir deux confrères jean
francis pécresse et polo bria messieurs
son sens bonsoir pas de sexisme ici
madame chabail pourtant dans la presse
c'est un déluge comme en témoigne votre
inventaire dans votre dernier livre le
deuxième sexe de la démocratie
apparemment aucun article sans allusion
à votre physique à votre coiffure à vos
tenues apparemment c'est indigne d'une
carte de presse pour vous c'est pas que
ce soit une carte de presse et que c'est
assez décevant il ya des propos qui
peuvent prêter à polémique ou qui
peuvent prêter à interprétation dont on
peut dire qu'ils sont sexistes pas
sexiste avoir un débat il y en a
d'autres en revanche qui sont carrément
outrancier ou injurieux donc là oui
c'est plutôt un besoin d'une carte de
presse et le dernier article qui vous
est consacré j'ai regardé c'est la
double page enfin une double page il ya
trois pages au total dans le point cette
semaine pour son titre et la photo qui
l'accompagnent en découvre ces ensembles
jusqu'où ira marlène schiappa alors
qu'on vous voit occupé avec un bouton de
votre corps sache comment est ce que
vous avez réagi
là franchement sincèrement je suis assez
blasé je me suis avec ironie j'me ça me
fait sourire jaune parce que je me dis
c'est incroyable d'un article qui
prétend relayé mais demont ciation du
sexisme de la presse et qui fait
exactement la même chose moi j'avais pas
connaissance de l'existence de cette
photo elle a dû être prise pendant une
séance sans que je m'en aperçoive
je trouve ça pas très élégant je suis
pas sûr qu'on aurait mis une photo d'un
homme en train de remonter sa braguette
avec un titre identique il ya eu
beaucoup de réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux beaucoup de femmes notamment on
trouve évidemment cette mise en page 6
et des hommes aussi bien sûr nous ici
nous l'avons trouvé aussi tout à fait
déplacée et sexiste trois grandes
questions vous seront posées au cours de
cette épreuve de vérité madame chat par
un dites-vous personne ne me fera taire
après la polémique bien sûr de la sphère
d'aval de prométhée vous l'égalité
salariale hommes femmes
à la fin du quinquennat 3 quelles
mesures en vue contre les violences
faites aux femmes et notamment dans la
rue c'est parti donc avec la première de
ces questions
[Musique]
bonsoir dans le chapitre ça va bien
exane mois après la polémique à la suite
de vos propos sur la faire des vagues et
l axe de défense de l'avocat du suspect
est ce que vous dites aujourd'hui
personne ne me fera taire en plusieurs
choses d'abord sur le fond je suis assez
surprise qu'on appelle ça une polémique
en l'espèce dans la sphère d'aval il
s'agit de la mort d'une femme
moi je me suis pas exprimé sur l'
affaire judiciaire je n'ai pas à
commenter une plaidoirie ou commenter
une décision de justice
j'ai analysé pour le combattre un
mécanisme sémantique et systémique qui
s'appelle le victimes de lemmings pour
parler le langage anglo saxons porter la
responsabilité de la violence à la
victime
et ça c'est systémique également puisque
très souvent quand une femme est bien
meurt sous les coups de son conjoint ce
qui arrive une fois tous les trois jours
en france on dit oui mais ne l'at-elle
pas chercher oui mais est-ce qu'elle
n'était pas difficile à vivre je vous
invite à découvrir le travail de
journaliste qui reprennent la
présentation notamment de la pqr avec
des choses invraisemblables utile elle
fait mal cuire les oeufs il la tue des
choses où on voit qu'on tourne en
dérision cela et qu'on met dans un
contexte assez assez désolant et
d'articles mais précisément c'est à dire
agathe recadrement de la victime par
l'avocat du suspect qui vous a fait
réagir c'est bien ça c'est le traitement
sémantique c'est le traitement
médiatique avocat
écoutez là c'était pas une plaidoirie
c'était quelque chose de médiatique avec
des reprises sempiternel en essayant de
porter atteinte à la victime et pour
répondre à la première partie de votre
question
personne ne me fera taire moi je suis
assez frappé de voir que le débat
il s'évite déportés et qu'on a vite
cessé de parler des violences conjugales
avec des choses assez aberrant de 6 pour
aux comptes marlène schiappa marin chapa
doit-elle se taire ou pas en fait l'idée
c'est que effectivement il ya des femmes
qui ont obligé à se taire et moi tant
qu'il y aura en france 84 milles viols
par an tant que tous les trois jours il
y aura une femme qui meurt sous les
coups de son conjoint
tant que ces choses là seront pas
abstraite mais qu'elles seront des
réalités et bien effectivement jeu
me tairai pas pour toutes les femmes qui
elles n'ont pas le choix de se taire ou
de ne pas se qualifier à terre c'est pas
ce qui est en cause du tout là c'est que
en l'occurrence vous avez commenter une
affaire en cours dont vous ne
connaissiez rien dont on ne connaît rien
personne ne connaît rien et de ce point
de vue vous êtes une récidiviste puisque
ou moi-même 2017 voulez vous est envoyé
en mission de récidivistes on extrait on
traîne ou presque à croire que moi mais
là on est dans des glissements en termes
de champ lexical la cible de chants et
ses cales de la culpabilité
une formule vous êtes récidiviste est
pas une c'est pas un terme de changement
dans le puits ce que au mois de mai 2010
est vous étiez intervenus dans une
affaire aussi dans un procès en
soutenant des feymen qui étaient jugés
devant le tribunal de grande instance de
paris donc on a l'impression que au fond
c'est coutumier chez vous d'intervenir
lorsqu'une affaire était en cours est ce
que ce sera
commencez par vous commencez alors par
le commencement les femen je ne suis pas
intervenu dans une affaire judiciaire
j'ai écrit une lettre au préfet mène sur
la question de la nudité politique des
femmes je n'ai pas dit monsieur le juge
ne condamnez pas les femen je ne me suis
pas immiscé dans un tribunal donc
gardons la mesure des choses et
remettons les choses dans leur contexte
ça c'est la première chose pour les
femen pour la deuxième moi je vous
invite à vous recentrer sur le sujet le
sujet c'est comment on fait pour
abaisser le seuil de tolérance de notre
société aux violences sexistes et
sexuelles
et ça c'est ma mission dans la lettre de
mission que m'a donné le premier
ministre edouard philippe
la première partie le premier paragraphe
me dit vous devrez vous servir de
l'action publique et de la parole
publique pour abaisser le seuil de
tolérance de la société aux violences
sexistes et sexuelles et abaisser ce
seuil de tolérance ça commence par
dénoncer la réalité de ces violences
alors les réactions ont été assez vives
vous avez été finalement été soutenu un
par le gouvernement même si monsieur
questionnaire lui
nous visions un peu différente je vous
propose d'écouter l'avocat daniel soulez
larivière alors voilà ce qu'il a entendu
lui chez vous mais voilà sa réaction il
le dit à samia de sheer je suis tout à
fait en osmose avec son son combat mais
quand il ya une affaire judiciaire il
c'est grave il ya quelqu'un qui est mis
en cause est quelqu'un qui bénéficie
d'une présomption d'innocence et donc il
n'est pas possible de critiquer les les
avocats qui le défendent et qui essaie
de trouver des explications
donc c'est pas parce que il donne des
explications que ils sont coupables
d'être anti féministe ou en eau pour les
femmes battues c'est absurde al-allagy
si vous voulez plus comme un internaute
que comme une queue comme un ministre tu
as mon point de vue je répondais vous je
sais pas répond quoi que ce soit je suis
extrêmement respectueuse de l'état de
droit des droits de la défense chaque
personne qui est mise en cause a le
droit d'être défendu et d'avoir un
avocat c'est la base et jamais je n'ai
contester cela ait jamais vous
m'entendrez contester cela chaque avocat
a au demeurant le droit de choisir la
ligne de défense dans le cas de sa
plaidoirie et dans le cadre du programme
en mai je n'ai pas à donner aux avocats
les bons et les mauvais points ça n'est
pas ce que j'ai fait je vous invite à
relire mon expression exact qui était de
partir du traitement sémantique de cette
affaire en particulier pour élargir plus
généralement en dix ans le féminicide
est ceci et cela
je sais que d'initier dans tout ça il ya
deux définitions différentes du
féminicide qui sont utilisés notamment
par des sociologues
la première c'est tout ce qui vise à
éliminer les femmes parce qu'elles sont
des femmes
par exemple dans certains pays dans
lesquels il arrive qu'on tue à la
naissance des petites filles parce
qu'elles sont des filles la deuxième
définition c'est pour faire un parallèle
avec par exemple l'infanticide ou le
parricide et c'est le fait de tuer son
épouse sa compagne sa femme comme ça se
passe encore une fois tous les trois
jours en france
c'est ce que ce montrent donc donc code
pénal est ce que vous voulez précisément
pénaliser le féminicide alors que dans
le cas d'espèce quand on tue son
conjoint c'est déjà la peine de
réclusion à la perpétuité qui ont couru
c'est pas mon propos ça fait pas partie
des engagements de campagne du président
de la république il ya beaucoup de
choses
ya beaucoup de choses dont on parle et
qui ne sont pas du ressort des
politiques publiques à proprement parler
là je vous explique depuis tout à
l'heure que c'est un combat culturel ça
sert d'en parler parce que le simple
fait que j'ai mis un hashtag féminicide
dans un tweet fait que vous me posez la
question pour demander ce que c'est
qu'un féminicide et qu'il ya eu des
dizaines d'articles disant qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un féminicide et qu'on a pu
alerter sur c'est à moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que ça ne sont pas des faits
divers isolé
quand vous avez tous les trois jours
sandrine salima fatima marie-odile qui
sont assassinés ou qui sont chez eux ou
qui sont roués de coups jusqu'à la mort
par leur conjoint ou leur ex conjoint
c'est quelque chose de systémique ça
n'est pas en fait divers plus un fait
divers plus un fait divers
qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'être sur
cette affaire soutenu par nicolas dupont
aignan et jean luc mélenchon au nom de
la liberté de parole et mais pas par le
président fin par le chef de file dans
marge de la république en marche
christophe castaner mais alors d'abord
j'observe que j'ai été soutenu
effectivement par jean luc mélenchon pas
au nom de la liberté de parole mais au
nom de ce combat et nous avons échangé
ensuite par sms et il est très clair que
jean luc mélenchon soutient la lutte
contre les violences envers les femmes
de la même manière que l'ancien ministre
aurait chipée ti ou que manuel valls qui
s'est exprimé aussi très clairement pour
dire qu'il soutenait cela en ce qui
concerne le gouvernement benjamin
griveaux qui est le porte parole du
gouvernement s'est exprimé au nom du
gouvernement en des termes très
sympathique et de soutien à mon égard
pour ce que je faisais et le premier
ministre m'a téléphoné lui même pour me
rappeler son soutien à la fois sur le
fond mais aussi sur la méthode donc je
me sens très soutenu et en face à la
réforme aussi c'est à dire sur votre
intervention dans cette dans cette
affaire d'aval edouard philippe
vous êtes dit qu'ils approuvaient votre
manière de moi je voulais je vous invite
à regarder les différents arts si vous
êtes en train de modifier dans
lesquelles la source était matignon et
il était dit qu'il y avait un soutien
très manifeste est encourageant à ce que
je faisais alors il arrive que la presse
soit paradoxale elle peut vous reprocher
de trop parler voire de ne pas assez
parlé par exemple dans la sphère tariq
ramadan avec l'amour sa mise en examen
dans cette affaire les accusatrices on
le sait ont été longtemps conspué
dénoncé à insulter est-ce que vous
rendez hommage au courage des femmes qui
ont dénoncé le théologien parmi lesquels
la journaliste caroline fourest
sachant que certaines restent encore
aujourd'hui menacée alors on voit ce
qu'on veut voir et on entend ce qu'on
veut entendre c'est à dire
qu'effectivement vous l'avez souligné
c'est très paradoxal on peut pas me
reprocher à la fois de trop m'exprimer
et en même temps de ne pas assez
m'exprimer et d'ailleurs sur le
traitement médiatique des différentes
affaires si je ne mettais pas exprimer
ça m'aurait été reprochés en ce qui
concerne tariq ramadan et bien je me
suis exprimé moi je vous invite à
regarder le replay une émission de votre
consoeur ruth elkrief qui date déjà d'il
ya quelques temps et d'une autre de
votre autre concert sonia mabrouk dans
ces deux émissions de me semble-t-il
je m'étais exprimé en rappelant le livre
de nda ayari qui est une écrivaine et
qui racontait dans ce livre les viols
qu'elle avait subi à l'époque 102 mais
tariq ramadan mais qui en faisait un
réussir sa mise en examen incite
d'autres femmes à s'exprimer à porter
plainte
mais de la même manière pour tous c'est
à dire que moi j'ai toujours dit que les
phénomène massif de libération de la
parole et je fais assez observatrice on
regarde donc d'un côté on salue la
libération de la parole des femmes et
que de l'autre côté on dit il faut avec
des femmes se taisent mais dans le cadre
de ce grand mouvement de libération de
la parole j'ai toujours incité à
judiciariser est toujours dit que la
justice elle ne se rend pas dans les
réseaux sociaux ou dans la presse mais
qu'il faut que les femmes allaient
déposer plainte et que ce soit instruit
par la justice qui tranche une fille née
sur la culpabilité ou non d'avoir des
politiques plusieurs associations d'aidé
aux victimes c'est notamment le cas des
associations contre les violences faites
aux femmes au travail
c'est aussi le cas du 39 19 se prennent
dans le manque de moyens ils vous disent
vous parlez beaucoup vous parlez bien
mais peut-être vous ne faites pas assez
les associations dire c'étaient des
propos qui ne sont pas les leurs alors
alain 39,19 est un déplacement
régulièrement et je ne crois pas qu'elle
dise vous parlez beaucoup mais vous
n'agissez pas puisque ont agi ensemble
qu'on les reçoit très souvent qu'on est
en train de travailler notamment à une
prochaine campagne pour abaisser le
seuil de tolérance de ces violences donc
ne leur prêtons pas des propos qui ne
sont pas les lie jeudi en tout cas
saturé voir démunis ce n'est pas la même
chose de dire je suis saturé de dire la
minus parle trop et n'agit pas du genre
à les calmer
les violences faites aux femmes au
travail at elle dit ça fait 13 ans que
nos subventions n'ont pas augmenté par
exemple et je crois que je n'étais pas
là il ya 13 ans donc remettre les choses
dans leur contexte aussi il ya plusieurs
choses et voulait souligner très bien
les mettant en parallèle il ya plusieurs
numéros téléphones actuellement dead
pour les femmes il ya le 39 19 vous
l'avez cité ya le numéro de la vf t il
ya numéro du collectif féministe contre
le viol et il ya les cidff les centres
d'information des droits des femmes et
des familles dans le choix qu'on a une
refonte globale à avoir là-dessus c'est
pour cette raison que j'ai installé un
groupe d'experts en ce qui concerne les
subventions avec des personnalités
qualifiées qui sera mis en oeuvre dans
les prochaines semaines et leur but ça
va être justement d'étudier
l'effectivité l'efficacité et la bonne
articulation entre les différentes
associations pour qui in fine et les
femmes qui ont besoin d'un service d'une
information puisse les trouver
facilement alors je le disais vous
publier un nouveau livre le deuxième
sexe de la démocratie constats et
propositions pour une juste
représentation des femmes dans l'espace
politique juste avant vous avez écrit le
livre laïcité point c'est le thème de la
première question de notre sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité le
gouvernement défend t-il suffisamment la
laïcité pas suffisamment 56%
suffisamment 43% où et comment est ce
que vous allez amplifier votre effort
tout d'abord j'observe que c'est
relativement équilibré on est sur les 45
ensuite je crois qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'actions qui vont être mises en
place il ya des atteintes à la laïcité
le gouvernement en prend acte et aj je
vous donne un exemple le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer qui installent des unités
laïcité qui sont à disposition pour que
dans chaque établissement et bien
justement les chefs d'établissement mais
tout le corps enseignant ne soient plus
seuls et ne soit plus démunis donc c'est
une manière vraiment de mettre à leur
disposition un certain nombre d'outils
et d'orientation et pour cela il est
appuyé par une forme de conseil des
sages de la laïcité qui définit à cet
égard d orientation plus précise
donc l'école est ce que lutter pour la
laïcité c'est lutter contre le sexisme
dans la société
oui je crois que ces sujets peuvent être
liés après comme je le dis dans le livre
ait point quoi je fais
je pense qu'il faut pas non plus
surchargées la laïcité c'est à dire que
quand la loi de 1905 a été votée il n'y
avait rien qui concernait les droits des
femmes ni l'égalité femmes-hommes je
pense que la laïcité c'est une des clés
pour défendre l'émancipation du genre
humain et la liberté de conscience et
notamment des femmes mais c'est pas une
clé suffisante en même temps que le chef
de l'état et est très critiquée par
l'opposition sur cette question alors on
lui reproche de manifester de deux
estime pour les religions il s'était
même inquiété emmanuel macron d'une
radicalisation la laïcité est ce que ces
mots sont ne sont pas malheureux
finalement de la part du du président de
république
moi je suis absolument pas choqué que le
président manifeste de l'estiment pour
les personnes comme tel ou tel site
santé drenica les utilisations au vaudou
laïcité poids lui dit la laïcité et
parfois radicales sable d'eau bouillante
et non ça me heurte absolument pas dans
la mesure où moi je sais très bien
justement pour venir des mouvements
laïques des gens qui sont radicaux ou
des gens qui peuvent être sectaire et là
il y en a partout
moi quand j'ai reçu la baie à marée
l'abbé grosjean dans mon ministère pour
discuter avec eux et débattre de nos
désaccords et voir si vous pouvez
trouver des points d'accord sur un
certain nombre de combats comme par
exemple la lutte contre la pornographie
à l'école il ya des gens qui se sont
offusqués en me disant que je ne devrais
pas les côtoyer je devrais pas leur
parler etc etc
je pense que des gens qui sont un peu
radicaux ou sectaires on peut en trouver
dans twilight
on en trouve absolument pas question de
laïcité radicale c'est ça existe comme
comme risque si je sais pas là on parle
de propos rapportés qui sont en plus un
petit peu anciens et rapportée du prison
la république je ne sais pas si les a
tenus au paj pa moi vous les expliciter
allez deuxième partie de l'épreuve de
vérité avec la deuxième question que
l'on vous a annoncé hier un instant
[Musique]
jean-francis pécresse
vous connaissez le chiffre à travail
égal les femmes gagnent 9 % de moins que
les hommes est ce que vous promettez
l'égalité salariale à la fin de ce
quinquennat goûter en tout cas on va
tout faire pour gagner deux siècles
parce que le world economic forum a
calculé que l'égalité professionnelle
entre les femmes et les hommes au niveau
mondial seraient atteints olemps 2234
donc nous ce que nous disons avec le
président de la république avec le
gouvernement c'est que nous voulons
gagner deux siècles et quelques et faire
en sorte de ne pas rester dans l'inertie
en attendant que ce jour arrive c'est
pour ça qu'on s'attaque à tout le
système qui produit ces inégalités de
salaires eh bien on s'adapte on
justement à ce système vous savez que
parmi ces causes il ya notamment les
ruptures de carrière pour les femmes
c'est pour ça que nous avons confié une
mission sur l'harmonisation du congé
maternité à une députée de la délégation
aux droits des femmes sa présidente
nous attaquons aussi au sujet du congé
paternité nous avons commandé avec
gérald darmanin muriel pénicaud et agnès
buzyn une mission à l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales sur le
congé paternité pour voir comment ce que
les employeurs ou des sociologues
appellent le risque de maternité peut
être partagée avec la paternité
ces congés va être allongée et bien il
ya une mission qui est en train de
plancher l'orientation
alors écoutez on leur demande d'étudier
d'abord ce qui se passe à l'étranger
puisque vous savez qu'il ya des des
systèmes assez disparates y compris au
sein de l'europe en italie en allemagne
a très peu de jours dans des pays
nordiques a plus de jour et qui sont
mieux rémunérés donc on leur demande
d'étudier sa de le budget était aussi
pour voir ce que cela coûterait à qui
étaient là alors vous avez marqué
beaucoup beaucoup c'était d'ailleurs la
couverture de l'observateur et semaine
dernière beaucoup estiment que la seule
façon de faire bouger les choses c'est
de rendre ce congé paternité obligatoire
et vous vous refusez c'est un jeune et
refuse c'est que favorable alors écoutez
moi c'est un sujet qui est au delà
d'être un sujet de suite pour je suis
contre un sujet symbolique ou totémique
c'est un sujet que c'est éminemment
technique elle pendant dix ans vous avez
peut-être que j'ai présidé un réseau de
mer à cuire et produit un certain nombre
d'études et écrit des livres comme
plafond de mer sur les liens entre la
parentalité et la carrière des femmes et
des hommes
en ce qui concerne le paternel le congé
paternité ce qu'on observe c'est que
plus de 70 % des pères prennent leur
congé paternité
certains ne prennent pas pourquoi un
problème culturel
ils pensent qu'on va leur refuser
ne savent pas que l'employeur n'a pas le
droit de refuser un congé paternité
donc là qu'est ce qu'on ferme à
contacter la caf dès lors que j'ai été
nommé pour communiquer plus massivement
en direction des futurs et jeunes pères
et deuxième frein et bien
l'indemnisation c'est à dire qu'il ya
certes un père qui ne sont pas assez
indemnisés qui ne s'estiment pas
indemnisé puisque c'est plafonné et donc
qui se bricolent une sorte de congé
paternité à eux mêmes avec des rtt et
des congés payés etc
c'est pour ça que je crois que le levier
ça peut être aussi l'augmentation de
l'indemnisation mais pour en revenir à
des hommes femmes
votre collègue au gouvernement mais les
pénicaud kyi ministre du travail
alors elle juge la situation
inadmissible mais une bonne loi mais
elle ne veut pas d'une nouvelle droite
il faut faire confiance aux entreprises
c'est ça la solution non l'idée c'est de
se dire vous savez on a un système
pléthorique de loi sur l'égalité
professionnelle la première vraiment dur
c'était yvette roudy en 83 et puis à
avant il y avait d'autres dispositions
qui avaient été prises mais qui sont
d'abord pas connu ni des femmes
elles-mêmes ni des employeurs mais qui
ne sont pas non plus appliqué
nous voulons renforcer les contrôles
aléatoires comme l'a annoncé le
président de la république le 25
novembre dernier pour faire en sorte que
tous les dispositifs légaux existent je
vous donne un exemple en ce qui concerne
l'état puisque l'état pour l'instant
n'est pas assez exemplaire sur cette
question c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
en ce qui concerne l'état nous voulons
faire appliquer la loi sauvadet elle
prévoit des quotas de féminisation et
elle prévoit 90 mille euros de pénalités
par unité d'emploi manquants or je me
suis aperçu en rentrant gouvernement
avec mon collègue ministre de l'action
des comptes publics qu'il n'y avait pas
de système pour aller contrôler
véritablement cela l'application et
pourra les réaffecter au budget d'état
les pénalités donc ça c'est un exemple
flagrant d'une loi qui existe qui est
une bonne loi et qui n'est pas appliquée
donc nous ce que nous voulons faire
c'est appliquer toutes ces lois qui
existent avec ces contrôles aléatoires
renforcée avec des sanctions quand c'est
nécessaire mais aussi avec des mesures
telles que le name and shame qui était
un engagement campagne du président de
la république nommé dénoncer les
entreprises récalcitrantes
et puis aussi accompagner les
entreprises qui elles manifestent un bon
vouloir
mais je vous propose d'écouter sur ce
thème sophie binet de la cgt qui elle
réclame d'autres mesures
encore
l'islande est un des pays du monde dans
lesquels il y a moins d'écart entre les
femmes et les hommes l'islande vient
mettre en oeuvre au 1er janvier 2018
une loi qui inverse la charge de la
preuve c'est à dire qu'elles forcent les
entreprises a prouvé qu'elle ne
discrimine pas si les entreprises ne
sont pas capables de faire cette preuve
elles sont automatiquement sanctionné
eh bien pourquoi ne pas mettre en oeuvre
une loi de ce type là en france de façon
à généraliser les sanctions et à mettre
en oeuvre une obligation de résultat au
lieu de la simple obligation moyens que
nous avons aujourd'hui en france et qui
est totalement insuffisante alors
pourquoi alors il ya de blagueur le
résultat alors deux choses d'abord cette
fois qui a été prise leur mission nous
la regarder vraiment et on a analysé
très attentivement
elle est assez ingrat elle est assez
similaire à un certain nombre de lois
qui existent en france
ensuite moi je peux pas laisser dire
qu'en france il ya juste une déclaration
d'intention ou une obligation de moyens
il ya une obligation de résultat et
d'ailleurs les entreprises se risque un
certain nombre de pénalités allant
jusqu'à 1% de la masse salariale si
elles ne respectent pas leurs
obligations en matière d'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes
l'enjeu il n'est pas s'étendre sur les
scènes c'est un plan d'action c'est la
loi de 2012 qui oblige chacun de chaque
entreprise ça avec derrière des
frontières l'égalité salariale en les 5
supporte également si si vous êtes
obligés de payer 2 vous ne pouvez pas
discriminer c'est interdit en france de
payer passion mais si c'est de la
discrimination payer moi une femme qu'un
homme à poste égal parce qu'elle est une
femme c'est de la discrimination
ça c'est interdit et c'est pour ça que
j'ai signé une convention avec le
défenseur des droits jacques toubon cet
été et que demain d'ailleurs il va
présenter un nouveau plan sur le
harcèlement sexuel au travail parce que
moi je rappelle qu'on peut saisir le
défenseur des droits en france on peut
saisir
on peut faire appel à des délégués et à
des syndicats tels que la cgt et tous
les autres mais on peut aussi faire
appel à l'inspection du travail
il est interdit de discriminer donc de
moins bien payés des femmes que les
hommes à poste égal en france sa
transparence des salaires c'est une
bonne idée
ou une fausse bonne idée écoutez c'est
une mesure qu'on est en train
d'investiguer effectivement là encore je
pense qu'il faut pas se contenter du
total mais regardez comment on la met en
oeuvre
comment l'appliquer donc le conseil
supérieur d'égalité professionnelle que
je préside et dont muriel pénicaud est
également vice présidente est en train
d'investiguer cela il ya des logiciels
qui existent en suisse par exemple comme
logique qui permet de facilement aux
entreprises de calculer leurs écarts de
salaires il ya des entreprises qui
commencent à le faire sont anonymes
voilà absolument pour avoir des
pourcentages oui bien sûr l'idée sais
pas pourquoi pas donner les noms je ne
sais pas si vous n'êtes pas pour le
lancement du hashtag balance la
disparité salariale
écoutez en ce qui concerne les
employeurs pourquoi pas mais je crois
que l'idée ça n'ait pas demandé le
salaire 2 me sur intel madame untel
monsieur untel l'idée c'est d'avoir les
écarts de salaire en pourcentage l'oréal
par exemple donnent ces données
salariales à l'ined et l'ined de façon
indépendante calcul les disparités les
différences de traitement femme homme et
cela permet ensuite à l'entreprise de
corriger il ya au moins un domaine dans
lequel la france semble peut-être
exemplaire je ne sais pas vous allez
pouvoir nous le dira oui dites moi c'est
la présence des femmes dans les conseils
d'administration vous allez avoir
bientôt une communication à new york sur
ce thème là alors j'étais la semaine
dernière en réalité j'étais
effectivement à new york puisque on
avait un gros événement sur ce sujet en
partenariat entre la france et le canada
et la liste auprès de justin trudeau
maria moncef était présente et avec nos
partenaires américains parce
qu'effectivement la france est de mieux
en mieux placés sur quels sont les
pourcentages écouter la remontée on a
réussi à atteindre 37% et ensuite à être
autour de 40 % ce qui est bien et ce qui
nous prouve qu'on a doublé le chiffre
grâce aux quotas en quelques années
depuis 2012 et dans d'autres pays il n'y
a pas de quotas et ça ne progresse pas
donc en termes de diplomatie
la france porte ce message de dire vous
voyez quand on a des quotas on peut
arriver à faire progresser la place des
femmes qu'elle l'ait fait est ce que
cette politique de quotas dans les
conseils il ya eu sur l'égalité dans les
entreprises au fond est ce qu'on s'est
pas trompé de combat
moi je pense qu'à construire de combat
des sociologues 10 c'est hier on s'est
trompé de combat en se focalisant sur
ses conseils mais ça n'appelle ça n'a eu
aucun effet d'entraînement
dans les entreprises il faut agir sur
tous les leviers je pense que s'il y
avait une baguette magique qui
permettait d'arriver à l'égalité
professionnelle femmes hommes avec une
seule mesure est bien les gens qui
étaient là avant nous l'aurait fait tout
simplement
donc je pense que il faut agir sur tout
même si tous ne touche pas tout le monde
le congé paternité bien ça n'a pas
d'impact sur par exemple les femmes qui
n'ont pas d'enfant ou qui ont des
enfants seuls etc
les la gouvernance des entreprises ça
n'a pas d'impact sur les personnes qui
sont au statut employé dans l'entreprise
ou un impact très mesurée et à long
terme puisque ça fait un appel d'air et
que c'est censé faire monter des cadres
et ensuite créer un dj moi je crois
qu'il faut agir surtout sur
l'orientation sur les interruptions de
carrière soit les politiques de
conciliation vie projet familial sur la
transparence sur le name and shame je
pense qu'il faut tout faire et être sur
tous les fronts en même temps avec un
objectif donc je reprends la question la
deuxième question que cette émission
alors je ne sais pas si vous promettez
l'égalité salariale à la fin du
quinquennat mais vous voulez réduire
l'écart à combien écoutez l'idée pour
nous c'est les et de gagner deux siècles
et demi je ne vous promets pas qu'il y
aura 0 % d'inégalité de salaire femmes
hommes
tout simplement parce que tout ne dépend
pas du gouvernement donc le gouvernement
fera tout ce qu'il peut comme jean nous
détailler mais on a besoin aussi que les
entreprises soient avec nous que les
partenaires sociaux soit avec nous les
syndicats le mettre à l'ordre du jour de
leurs négociations et que chacun fasse
appliquer écoutez que les au total war
déjà moi je pense qu'il faut que les
femmes 1 connaissent leurs droits de les
fasse appliquer est effectivement vous
avez raison il ya un certain nombre de
femmes qui ne connaissent pas leurs
droits au travail
moi j'étais frappé pendant la campagne
présidentielle quand je faisais des
ateliers avec des femmes pour préparer
le programme du président la république
certaine nous disait par exemple ça
pourrait être bien si vous pouvez avoir
une petite augmentation du retour du
congé maternité ou si on pouvait être
protégés du licenciement quelques
semaines quand on revient du congé
maternité
mais tout cela existe et déjà dans la
loi et beaucoup de femmes ne le savent
pas troisième partie tout de suite de
l'épreuve de vérité avec marlène
schiappa
[Musique]
et là la question c'est quelles sont les
mesures en vue puisque un texte de loi
est en préparation il est quasiment
finalisé je pense contre les violences
faites aux femmes notamment dans la rue
et c'était le thème de la deuxième
question de notre sondage opinionway
pour l'épreuve de vérité êtes vous
favorable ou non à la sanction du
harcèlement de rue favorables 68% opposé
30% donc vous voilà soutenu et encouragé
même si en vous écoutant depuis le début
de l'émission on sent qu'on n'a pas
besoin de vous encourager dans vos
combats madame fia pas si c'est toujours
bien vissé de jets privés pas c'est
qu'on écoutait y avait une étude
également de l'ifop et la fondation jean
jaurès il ya quelques semaines qui
montrait que 8 femmes sur 10 ont peur
quand elles sont seuls dans la rue le
soir donc crois qu'effectivement cette
insécurité spécifique pour reprendre les
propos du président quand il était en
campagne elle est vécue par les femmes
elle est ressentie et je crois qu'il ya
également un certain nombre d'hommes qui
ne cautionne pas du tout ces
comportements et qui sont rassurés à
l'idée de savoir comme ça serait
énormément pas la majorité
comment vous définissez et outrages
sexistes comment on définit comment vous
sanctionne qu'il sanctionne
ça paraît un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué alors comment l'on le définit
déjà c'est effectivement compliqué c'est
pour ça que j'ai installé un groupe de
cinq parlementaires d'options politiques
différents il ya des gens du modem de la
république en marche de de la nouvelle
gauche etc
et l'idée de ces cinq parlementaires
c'est de planches et de mener des
auditions ce qu'ils ont fait aux prêts à
la fois d'associations de citoyens mais
aussi des forces de l'ordre et d'un
certain nombre d'experts nous nous
allons créer un délit d' outrage
sexistes qui pourra être verbalisé en
flagrant délit par les forces de l'ordre
combien de l'appliquer là on est en
train de regarder en termes de montants
je crois que les députés ont recommandé
ce que rapport nous sera remis dans
quelques semaines ils ont recommandé que
ce soit une amende de classe 4 ce qui
laisse une fourchette entre 90 et 750
euros selon que vous payez immédiatement
que ce soit à aurait majoré que soit la
définition est guidée de la définition
c'est de dire que eh bien c'est tout
acte qui intimide qui visent à humilier
et intimider a outragé content parce que
j'ai vu un papier un tableau même dans
le figaro dans le parisien la semaine
dernière vous l'avez sont revus oui sur
les comportements qui devrait être
sanctionné on va le voir
alors on lit donc ça va des sifflements
aux commentaires sur le physique ou la
tenue vestimentaire en passant par les
réflexions sexistes jusqu'au regard
appuyé c'est pas sûr que ce soit le
contenu du rapport des députés il me
semble pas en tout cas qu'il soit fait
mon temps son pardon droit de regard
appuyé ou de commentaire parce qu'un
commentaire ça peut être aussi un
compliment une fois ça peut être quelque
chose de sympathique commentaires subtil
alors comment faire la différence entre
harcelé par un mot déplacé commentaires
subtil qui rend hommage à la beauté de
la personne que l'on affluence ce sont
des policiers et des magistrats qui met
sur ces questions bien sûr mais ils
m'ont dit si l'avenir toute allure et je
maison tout à fait raison de le faire
parce que la question pour nous c'est
l'application
il s'agit d'abord de dire que les lois
de la république interdisent d'intimider
de harceler les femmes dans l'espace
public ce qui n'est pas encore contenue
dans la loi actuellement d'une part et
donc ça ça aura valeur de pédagogie mais
d'autre part ils ont absolument raison
de le souligner ce qui est important
pour nous c'est comment on met cela en
oeuvre
c'est pour ça que le ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb a annoncé que
ça fera partie des priorités de la
police de la sécurité du quotidien et
que parmi ces dix mille policiers et
policières il y aura cette verbalisation
du harcèlement deux mois je crois très
sincèrement que les policiers les forces
de l'ordre sont en capacité totale
d'identifier le harcèlement de j'étais
encore le week-end dernier en sarthe
avec la gendarmerie et la police pour
travailler sur les violences envers les
femmes
est ce que me disent les policiers ils
vont d'armes aussi au demeurant c'est
qu'ils savent quand ils repèrent du
harcèlement de rue lorsqu'ils sont en
patrouille quand il voit une jeune fille
qui est intimidé qui est suivi qui est
menacée il le voit bien il s'agit pas de
mettre une amende pour quelqu'un qui
aurait dit vous avez un beau chapeau
vous êtes très séduisant ou très
séduisante ou est-ce qu'on peut discuter
etc
il s'agit vraiment d'intimidation de ce
qui crée un climat malaise ans pour les
femmes
effrayant et qui nous amène aux chiffres
que l'on évoqué tout à l'heure est ce
que cette loi malgré ces bonnes
intentions et les réalise c'est à dire
est ce que dans des quartiers
où la présence de la police et pour le
moins épisodiquement est la moindre
chance d'être appliquée au fond est ce
que c'est les vrais harceleur qui vont
être victimes de cette loi comme devrait
l'être et pas ce qui les force à l'heure
vous voyez ce que je veux dire enfin il
ya ben il ya des quartiers où les femmes
sont plus harcelée que d'autres et où la
police comme par hasard son nom est un
peu moins présente
est ce que cette loi est elle va pas
être appliqué là où elle est là
peut-être moins de raison de l'être que
d'autres d'être présent là et puis que
s'est exprimé là-dessus au roman il a
lancé la grande cause du quinquennat
donc à l'elysée le 25 novembre dernier
et il a expliqué que à les policiers de
la sécurité du cotisant seraient
déployés notamment pour 7 millions cette
mission pardon sur les lieux qui sont
sensibles donc ça peut être par exemple
aux abords des gares parce que c'est
effectivement parfois et souvent dans
des quartiers difficiles dit difficile
mais ça peut être aussi en plein centre
ville aux abords des gares moi comme je
voulais dit je suis élu du mans un des
points sensibles pour nous c'est le
trajet qui mène de la gare la place
principale qui est l'avenue du général
leclerc dans laquelle vous savez que si
vous passez à pied de nuit et bien vous
serez importuné par des bandes de
garçons ont deux jeunes hommes qui sont
la journée alors jean francis part de
certains quartiers dans certains
quartiers certaines femmes sont
harcelées effectivement mais parce qu
elle sortir en gym en bas de chez elle
ou parce qu'elles ont je ne sais pas les
épaules dénudées et comment est ce que
vous réagissez face à ce genre de
phénomènes comme très présent vous le
savez est ce que ce texte là aura une
utilité
écoutez moi je pense qu'il aura une
utilité justement également pour ces
femmes pour la liberté vestimentaire et
même la liberté de porter des vêtements
on va dire sexy pour faire court on va
tous assumer en garde et de s'habiller
comme on veut
cent autres restrictions que celles des
troubles à l'ordre public on en connaît
qui sont grands pour les hommes comme
pour les femmes pour ces femmes qui
souffrent qui n'osent pas sortir en bas
de chez elle
l'idée justement c'est que cette
verbalisation du harcèlement de rhumes
de l'outragé sexistes c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on l'a appelée outrage sexy ce
pour dire qu'il n'y a pas forcément de
phénomène de répétition et que ça peut
être même une fois même une fois ces
femmes que vous évoquez elles sortent
épaules dénudées ou en guinée je
quelqu'un essaye de les intimider et
bien il pourrait être verbalisé dans le
cadre du harcèlement de rues de
l'outragé sexistes l'idée c'est vraiment
de dire que ça fait partie des valeurs
républicaines et les lois de la
république
et bien ne tolère pas qu'on en timide
des femmes couleurs somme de s'habiller
de telle ou telle manière lors du reste
certaines choses changent s'en sont même
de nouvelles lois ses cadres la formule
1 par exemple r oui à plus de grid girls
girls sont si c'est une femme qui
accompagne les pilotes jusque là on va
les voir alors ça c'est fini en
formulant s'avoue satisfait ce n'était
pas une demande de madame est
effectivement comme je viens de vous
dire moi j'étais maire adjoint du mans
je suis toujours élu du mans il ya les
24 heures du mans là comme vous le savez
et sert sion qui est le patron de la seo
qui organise les 24 heures du mans avait
déjà pris la décision il ya quelques
années de cela
d'arrêter les gamers moi je pense que le
message qu'on envoie derrière c'est un
message sur la place des femmes dans le
sport ce matin j'étais avec laura
flessel nous étions en train de lancer
notamment avec le csa un programme sur
le sport féminin toujours pour valoriser
et encourager la pratique sportive des
femmes et l'idée c'est de dire que d'un
les femmes dans le sport elle ne sont
pas forcément celles qui ont des jolies
robes et qui font une bise aux champions
c'est que se dégage d'un jour sur le
tour de france ça perdure ici et non de
tous absolument mais d'ailleurs je fais
un événement prochainement justement -
avec un député qui s'appelle damien
pichereau qui est mobilisé sur les
sujets de la mobilité et notamment de la
course automobile
au fait ça aux 24 heures du mans et
l'idée justement c'est de discuter
ensemble avec les experts avec les gens
qui sont partie prenante de la façon
dont on fait exister des femmes
championne et pourquoi pas une femme qui
gagnerait les 24 heures du mans à qui
elle recevrait les congratulations
avocat pour ses parents un homme
m'écouter pourquoi bah écoutez pour
l'instant qu'est ce qu'on voit sur le
tour de france
à l'arrivée de chaque étape ce sont des
femmes potiche qui arrive avec avec des
bouquets save our hearts cette image
cette représentation de la femme c'est
ce que je vous disais ça derrière le
fait qu'une femme fasse une 10 avec un
bouquet en soi n'est pas gênant ce qui
est gênant c'est la représentation
derrière et le parallèle qu'on peut
faire avec le fait qu'il y ait très peu
de femmes sportives qu'ils soient
médiatisées autant que les âmes sparks
d'accord très bien on a abordé d'autres
sujets et notamment celui de la pma
alors c'est pour quand et
est-ce que vous avez bon espoir de faire
évoluer les opinions dans le sens de la
pma pour toutes les femmes
écoutez il ya les états généraux de la
bioéthique il y aurait sûrement qui dure
puisque ça se passe dans le cadre de la
révision de la loi bioéthique est dense
et ce dans le cadre de ces états
généraux il ya un débat citoyen donc
chacune et chacun peut apporter sa
pierre organisé son débat sous l'égide
du conseil national de l'éthique
l'idée c'est que ce débat débouche sur
la révision de la loi bioéthique qui
sera portée par la mise de la santé et
des solidarités
vous avez dû aux partisans de la pma
d'ignorer la manif pour tous vous leur
avez dit mais c'est les faire dans dans
leur coin les huiles sega manif pour
tous énervés tout seul et c'est vrai que
c'est votre message
le message du gouvernement c'est la
bienveillance et l'apaisement donc
effectivement moi je crois que si on
veut avoir un débat apaisé il faut
procéder de la sorte
pourquoi je leur dis ça d'abord je vais
pas exactement ces termes mais pourquoi
je dis cela c'est parce que moi
j'observe et notamment le rapport sos
homophobie qui calcule les actes
homophobes et qui en fait est à chaque
année nous montre qu'à chaque fois qu'il
ya des débats de société
eh bien il a une forme d' effets
néfastes derrière avec une augmentation
des actes homophobes
moi ma préoccupation c'est faire en
sorte que les couples de femmes les
couples d'hommes qui joue qui se promène
dans la rue qui vont aller au restaurant
le soir de la saint-valentin qui amènent
leurs enfants dans le parc à l'école ne
soient pas importunées ils ne soient pas
des victimes de parole ou d'actes
homophobes qui serait blessant et pour
eux et pour leurs enfants en marge des
débats c'est ma préoccupation
en tous les cas je me souviens que
emmanuel macron durant la campagne
avaient critiqué un peu le précédent
gouvernement pour avoir un peu pour
résumer hystériser le
débat sur le mariage porthos vous
souvenez vous voulez vous éviter cet
écueil la même si on entend des
critiques chez les adversaires de la pma
pour toutes qu'ils disent mais ça ouvre
la voie à la gpa alors que leur répondez
vous est ce que vous l'avez vous ne
serez pas de toute façon
interpellé et certainement durement et
que je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord effectivement vous avez raison
de le rappeler le président la
république avait pris deux engagements
pendant la campagne il a pris un
engagement de fonds en disant qu'il
proposerait à la représentation
nationale l'ouverture de la tm à toutes
les femmes
mais il a pris aussi un engagement de
forme en disant que son engagement de
forme c'était qu'il voulait avoir un
large débat citoyen qui associe tout le
monde et que personne ne soit d'office
rejeter ou exclus de ce débat et je
crois que c'est une bonne méthode parce
que c'est avec cette méthode qu'on peut
arriver à une forme de consensus ou en
tout cas de débat qui soit canalisée
alors bernard rappaz vous avez une
origine corse où vous en êtes fier
manifestement puisque je voulais porter
autour du cou est ce que le chef de
l'état va encore se demain enfin enfin
arrive ce soir ou demain matin
est ce qu'il doit faire un geste des
concessions vis à vis des corses et
notamment des autonomistes corses
vous avez rappelé effectivement le
présent la république va encore demain
effectivement je l'accompagnerai je ne
serai pas seul avec d'autres pour ce
pour ce déplacement
moi je crois que le présent la
république s'exprimera demain ou après
demain ou en tout cas au cours de son
voyage en corse à il dit à quelle est sa
ligne à cet égard mais qu'est ce que
vous souhaitez vous comme les
nationalistes hyper majoritaire dans
votre île que
le gouvernement l'a a une chance
historique à saisir en répondant aux
revendications en corse
effectivement moi ce que j'observe c'est
que d'abord démocratie existe et je suis
extrêmement respectueuse de la
démocratie
nous avons deux présidents jean guy
talamoni gilles synonyme qui sont les co
président de la collectivité
territoriale
ils sont démocratiquement élu il porte
des revendications c'est tout à fait
normal que le président de la république
échanger discuter avec eux au demeurant
ils ont déjà été reçus par le premier
ministre edouard philippe
par contre comme françois de rugy et
d'autres responsables politiques donc
moi je crois qu'il ya un dialogue qui
s'initient jacqueline gourault a été
chargé de suivre ses dossiers pour le
gouvernement et je trouve que c'est un
très bon signal que d'avoir une personne
qui est pleinement en charge après
savoir ce que vaut vous pensez est ce
que vous estimez que certaines
revendications sont légitimes ou par la
langue corse sur la langue corse sur le
statut des corses de la politique aussi
est ce que ça existe en france des
prisonniers politiques par exemple alors
vous connaissez très bien mieux que nous
c'est problème vous êtes corse
écoutez moi je crois que il conviendrait
d'attendre l'expression du président ce
n'est pas que je veuille échappé au
débat je le prendrai bien volontiers
comme je crois qu'on nous reproche pas
en général de passer m'exprimer à bien
revenir la semaine prochaine pour parler
avec vous de ce qui aura été dit par le
président la république mais vous
comprendrez que ça n'est pas à moi
secrétaire d'état de donner mon avis sur
un plateau avec le chef de l'état
est ce que vous espérez qu'ils
rappellent que la république est une et
indivisible
vous serez à ses côtés moi je n'ai pas
d'espérance vis-à-vis du président la
république ça n'est pas comme ça que ça
se passe
je suis dans son gouvernement je vais en
oeuvre son programme
et je suis bien sûr totalement en phase
et tout ce que peut vous proposer le
président l'a expliqué à mes pas de
débat à ce sujet autre question pour le
dire différemment est ce que vous
estimez vous qui êtes record ce qui a eu
deux spécificités corse que les autres
régions françaises nom pareil ce qu'il
faut reconnaître une spécificité
particulière à la corse et je crois que
bien sûr il ya des spécifités ne
serait-ce que géographique
la vie insulaire n'est pas là
même que la vie continental donc
effectivement il ya des particularités
certaines sont déjà reconnu le ministre
d'état ministre de l'intérieur gérard
collomb s'est exprimé à ce sujet dans
une question au gouvernement à laquelle
il avait répondu en reconnaissant aussi
bien sûr qu'il y a des particularités
c'est pour ça aux deux grands qu'il ya
une collectivité territoriale c'est une
forme de reconnaissance institutionnelle
de ses particularités est ce que vous
êtes inquiète du décrochage du président
et du gouvernement dans les derniers
sondages d'opinion avec également le
coup dur que représentent les deux
élections législatives partielles de ce
dimanche
non je serai pas ça comme ça je pense
que d'abord les élections législatives
partielles je crois qu'il ne faut pas en
tirer des leçons nationales trop vite il
s'agit de deux élections partielles
généralement les élections partielles ne
sont pas favorables au gouvernement qui
est en place c'est un peu la rocade les
attentes notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat ne sont pas satisfaites il ya
une forme de pression moi je comprends
et je partage tout à fait leur patience
de tous nos concitoyens y compris sur
les sujets qui sont les miens les gens
ont voté pour présent la république pour
une transformation les attendent les
résultats cette transformation nous
sommes au travail nous y travaillons je
crois qu'il faudra hélas tout petit peu
les résultats effectifs sur la vie
quotidienne globale de nos concitoyens
on va se séparer sur quelques notes de
musique et des images également du
groupe de rap big flo et oli je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez ces belles
chansons dommage il est question
notamment d'une femme qui une femme qui
succombe sous les coups de son mari on
regarde et on écoute volina les
discrètes
elle oublie qu'elle est belle elle a
surtout le corps des tâches de la
couleur du ciel
son mari rande bientôt elle veut même
pas y penser quand il lui prend le bras
c'est pas pour la faire danser
elle repense à la mairie cette décision
qu'elle a prise à cet après midi où elle
avait fait sa valise
à venir un fils a élevé après la
dernière danse s'est pas relevé elle
aurait dû y aller elle aurait dû le
faire
crois moi on a tous dit à ces dommages
assez dommage c'est peut-être la dette
parfois les artistes s'emparent de tous
vos dossiers madame chapeau et les
chanteurs le cinéma aussi bien sûr on a
vu récemment le film numéro une
hier vous étiez une projection bien su
résister avec emmanuelle devos oui sur
une ferme d'affluence dans les affaires
et puis mercredi sort jusqu'à la garde
avec léa drucker sur les violences
conjugales le cinéma s'empare aussi aux
états unis de la question des femmes
rien à voir avec tafer weinstein sais
pas si vous avez vu pentagone peppers
avec ta magnifique métamorphose la
propriétaire du washington post
vous êtes vous sentez soutenu c'est pour
ça que vous même d'ailleurs vous allez
monter sur scène pour jouer les
monologues du vagin vous vous y préparer
parce que c'est une pièce qui est pas
évidente à jouer
je me souviens avoir vu ses volumes en
ce qui concerne les monologues du vagin
on reverse la recette association qui
s'appelle le collectif féministe contre
le viol parce que ça leur fera une
lecture d'une lecture absolument je
voudrais juste saluer si vous me
permettez devenir un tout petit peu en
arrière et salué ce que font ces deux
rappeurs dit que les audi quand j'ai
découvert ce morceau par l'intermédiaire
de ma fille de 11 ans qui l'écoutent
avec ses copines et je crois que le fait
que des idoles et des rappeurs qui sont
écoutés par les jeunes ça peut permettre
parfois de passer des messages de
société et abaisser ce seuil de
tolérance de la société aux violences en
interpellant y compris les plus jeunes à
ce phénomène dont je voudrais vraiment
il a remercié les pays trente deux
frères toulousain merveilleux plein de
talent merci à vous merci messieurs
bonsoir à tous et sa semaine prochaine
ici à votre place
la parité sera pierre moscovici
[Musique]
ce